Recently had some conjunctival eye hemorrhage, maybe due to supplements. Should I run the
Bursted Eye Vessel Rife program and does it tend to strengthen the capillaries. I also have
Von Wilderberg blood clotting disorder. I would say, yeah, you're not going to hurt yourself
writing any of the frequencies on the rife except the caveat that I've always said is if you're
running kill programs on, let's say, Lyme disease and you killed bacteria, grab negative bacteria
too quickly. But no, the only caveat to this is, I don't know how well it's going to work. I mean,
when I said, I don't know that I don't remember anybody ever telling me they had this condition
that they ran the rife program for it, period. So I have no data whether it's going to work or not.
So again, these are frequencies to help your body function better. They're not,
it's not going to miraculously cure anything, but it certainly can help heal, help your body heal
thing. So I would definitely give that a shot.